let's go next to our caller from the
five-one-six-- area code who's been
holding on for a while five one six
what's your name where you calling from
hey what's going on David names Anthony
what's up Anthony
you know what not much I got a I've been
going back and forth with my friend in
regards to a theory that I had because
you know I don't want to get on the show
for a while and at this point and when
it comes to Trump there's really no good
answer for it regardless if you try to
get them out or just as supporters there
doesn't seem to be any good answer so
while I can I'll ask you this question
my buddy always has a problem with
lettuce he says they're moving too fast
and my question to him is you know what
I agree it's you know I don't really
follow politics too much but do you
think the left is moving so quickly
because the right has held them back for
so long like things on just you know
basic like gay marriage and global like
global warming they've held them back
for so long so now they have a footing
they're trying to go to things what what
has the left done that's been super fast
like what's an example well that's
that's his argument that's and I'm just
trying to get like no matter what I
throw at him like I always try to bring
up Trump and like his press briefings
right and I tell I just show them an
example but one thing they've done very
well is just what about this person he
never seemed to answer the question
that's being asked about one particular
person you know but if your friend says
the left is moving too fast I don't know
that I'd talk about Trump's breast
briefings I'd say what is it what is the
left move too fast on because I haven't
I mean listen Obamacare it took the idea
of Obamacare was first proposed in like
the early 90s by the Heritage Foundation
and it was passed in 2010 so in 17 years
we got healthcare.gov and a rule about
pre-existing conditions and 26 year olds
that's that's too fast gay marriage the
first state to legalize gay marriage was
Massachusetts in I think it was 2003 in
2015 the Supreme Court that's 12 years
like I
we just say where has the let where is
the left moving so fast I don't see
anywhere that the left is moving fast
that you know what thank you because I
more or less whenever I try to bring
something up I'll say something like oh
they're doing this the green new deal
and I and I look I don't know the
details of it I just know that it's a
guideline like look it's an idea what's
the problem with just having an idea
it's like oh they're just doing that
I see so really what your friend is
saying here so here here's what your
friend is actually saying your friend is
not pointing to things that have been
done your friend is saying Democrats are
thinking too big
Democrats ideas are too forward looking
but I would point out if I were you
none of that stuff has been done none of
it has been done if you actually look at
listen Republicans want to ban all or
almost all abortions
that's whacked now they've done smaller
things at the state level but if I say
Republicans are moving too fast by
trying to ban all abortion I'm wrong
because they haven't actually moved
there they've been equally radical for a
long time
so tell your friend there's a difference
between an idea and actually doing stuff
and that in fact it's Republicans that
have been preventing any progress you
know what David I appreciate you taking
my call and I got other callers a great
job doing everything you do thank you so
much all right Anthony great to hear
from you